interview passos enfin cette basse et du
net
odile decq bonsoir alors contrairement à
ce que tu entends look pourrait laisser
croire
tu es architectes et ça tout à fait
[Applaudissements]
est ce que tu dis que les femmes
généralement dans l' architecture on
leur propose de soual architecture
intérieure soit des maisons
individuelles et finalement de toi pour
arriver à sortir de sa tata fait des
concours d'établissements publics c'est
ça c'est pour ça oui c'est à dire qu'en
fait simple c'est effectivement ce qu'on
va dire au tout début qu'à partir manger
tu es une farce à bien faire je ferai
très très bien les plans des cuisines
des placards et la menace alors comme un
des tous meilleurs l'allemand et je suis
mais comme ça on va me reconnaissais de
certains qualité qu'étaient les quelques
pratiques que je pouvais peut-être
montrer qu'on peut les appliquer à autre
chose et à ce moment là aux équipements
publics aux juges
ayrault tout autre chose que des maisons
j'aime appeler dans sa tête d'être une
femme quand même y en a un avantage
c'est davantage maintenant fait c'est tu
dessines quoi justement des banques
décret sophie des trucs vachement
sérieux en fait non les immeubles
tout à fait c'est très sérieux comme
métier quoi par exemple part des choses
actuellement je j'ai fait un immeuble de
logements à paris alors évidemment c'est
ce n'était pas des maisons du budget
annuel de logements à côté de la
villette
et puis dans lequel il ya tout un
travail sur les loggias des duplex
justement on essaie de renouveler un peu
le genre de l'immeuble et des petites
boîtes prise de partir autrement une
banque un certain extractif quelque
chose de très sérieux pour une banque en
fait c'est une usine bancaire une usine
dans lesquelles ils magnifique travail
traite les chèques et cartes magnétiques
et c'est une usine de production
bancaire et du matériel tutu prévert
c'est quoi il ya plein de matériaux que
j'aime bien mais effectivement je viens
de métal et verre et j'aime bien le
métal et le trajet bien le vert pour sa
transparence parce que c'est quand même
la kids l'architecturé contemporaine pas
rentrer la lumière jeudi
et puis le métal parce que c'est la
précision c'est la rigueur c'est la
souci du détail des choses qu'on doit
décider jusqu'où nous complètement
gothique et rick très technique en fait
un peu ça le paradoxe fois deux breaks
c'est vrai que tu as étudié la la
reconstruction des villes allemandes oui
j'ai étudié juste après mon diplôme j'ai
été envoyé par un truc très très
officielle qui s'appelle la mission
interministérielle pour la qualité des
constructions publiques pour aller voir
comment ça se passait dans les villes
allemandes
pourtant dans ce sens en allemagne et
est parallèlement j'avais obtenu une
bourse également d'une masse d'une
institution allemande qui voulait que je
fasse une étude d'urbanisme pour vous et
donc j'essaie de regarder comment les
villes allemandes avait été reconstruite
après guerre j'avais découvert qu'elles
avaient toutes des problèmes d'identité
il y en a qui se sont reconstruites à
l'identique d'autres codes carrément
fait table rase du passé quand c'est des
trucs hyper moderne permanent exemple un
problème évidemment il y en a d'autres
qui ont essayé de moduler un petit peu
entre les deux c'était super intéressant
car tu as fait un truc très étonnant si
c'est les fameuses mac est
invraisemblable c'est oui parce que
c'est à dire tu considères la maquette
communes comme une oeuvre d'art
finalement et pas seulement comme
quelque chose de technique est digne
d'être exposé quoi oui les maquettes à
sa demande à vraisemblable que le nom
parce qu'en fait elles sont tout à fait
vraisemblable dans la mesure où ce sont
toutes des maquettes de projets faits
répondront et réaliser mais ça exprime
c'est plutôt des maquettes et créé le
concept du projet c'est à ce moment les
phases les phases intermédiaires entre
les premiers dessins et
et la réalisation qui a fait pas une
réduction du projet c'est ma quête de la
conception du projet taille miniature
fièrement les lignes de force qui a
prédominé à la construction du projet du
srec illicite était pas au québec alors
si je fais pas je pourrai pas être une
autre femme architecte parce qu'il n'a
pas vous pouvez
notre musique est peut-être le corbusier
et qui tu voudrais surtout pas être ça
marche i tech
si tu étais pas odile decq d'autres aux
abords qui s'est excusé après qui fait
des trucs qui sont très organique très
dégoulinant j'aime pas du tout même pas
du tout qu'est ce que tu penses de ce
que fait jean nouvel par exemple c'est
génial ouais c'est vraiment génial
et les immeubles que fait philippe
starck je la prends tu les as vus j'ai
vu un projet oui je sais pas trop quoi
en penser
parce que je sais pas si c'est pas
qu'une enveloppe et qui se serait ce
qu'à l'intérieur alors j'ai pas vu je
peux pas dire c'est beau fils tu aimes
pas alors j'ai du mal ça dure
j'ai du mal et en même temps c'est bien
fait un bon travail c'est bien fun mais
j'ai du mal du site était maître de
paris au niveau architectural pendant
quelques temps tu détruirait quoi un
bâtiment que j'aime pas du tout ce
nouvel hôtel drouot
ouais pourquoi je trouve une guerre
qu'un quand un truc je n'ai pas beaucoup
non plus et l'opéra bastille de nouveaux
tarifs et uruguay
tu détruis red bull est le terreau
l'opéra de la bastille et puis et puis
je construirai sur leurs avoirs après ce
que tu commandes et construire sur bercy
ouais parce que je trouve ça super stock
il ya tout le soubassement mais madrid
pour ce faire ils ont construit un
immeuble au dessus alors tu construiras
quoi maintenant si on me disait comme ça
fait un menu brand fait un immeuble fait
un quartier tu ferais quoi ce que des
tours détours en plein paris en plein
paris et les tours avec un tissu dans un
qui survint way we ou offrez ou du tour
j'avais imaginé un jour qu'on pouvait en
faire à la pointe de l'île et recycle
tas de copains mais oui parce que fait
c'est une drogue pure et donc ça va être
marquée par un signal à toi il ya juste
l'histoire un doute rock qui n'a pas
vraiment l'existence était dangereuse
quand la pub c'était influence est parti
alors on travaille aujourd'hui petite
influence
actuellement ce qui m'influence + gyr
est presque c'est le travail des anglais
comme poster rogers des gens qui
travaillent énormément le métal les
ingénieurs anglais qui
toute la technique tout là tout le
travail sur la transparence
ouais les verts sont fabuleux à moi des
choses qui peuvent devenir totalement
immatériel alors que ça pèse des tonnes
mais pyramide ça te plaît alors ça me
plaît et en même temps je trouve qu'il
ya presque trop structure ouais c'est
vrai elles étaient les mouvements et
transparent de l'extérieur qu'à
l'intérieur
si tu t'habilles toutefois car ces
demandes le tanit dans un truc sympa
anciens dans un vieil homme qu'il n'y a
pas de verre il n'y a pas de nom donc
cette gêne pas de faire habiter des gens
dont les douze autres a dit pas
finalement ah non mais j'aimerais bien
habiter maman habitait dans le jeu au
lieu dit la santé coûte quoi quand tu
travailles comme musique j'écoute pas
mal de rock ou du mozart
ah bon cari quoi comme rock quoi comme
rock
les gens qui ont des supers voit l'homme
succès
bah oui j'écoute sisters of mercy que
j'adore la pâte produite
j'écoute
sinead o'connor son premier jeu coûte
des voix des gens qui jouent avec leur
voix qui tout le monde qu'il est en
train des mélodies avec ça ou du mozart
ou du moins c'était super gai c'est vrai
que tu veux monter un groupe de rock et
qui va chanter ça faisait partie ça fait
partie longtemps de mes fantasmes de jeu
d'enfant pas de refrain d'adolescents de
presse que j'arrive pas à mener deux
carrières
c'est vrai que ton rêve se monter une
station orbitale dans fabre était alors
construit en fin s'est construit une
station orbitale dans ce que ça
représente comme choses totalement
achevée je vous dire que c'est là c'est
un univers qui doit tenir compte à la
fois d'urbanisme de la vie de tous les
jours de concert les petits détails les
concevoir les fluides line mécaniques
l'industrie enfin c'est vraiment très
très complexe et plus et contexte que ça
me prêter à ces jeunes pour espère en
faire une journée est fermé si on veut
donner une définition de toi dans le
dictionnaire ce serait quoi
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de nos
latitudes abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux